supremacy when you land on an alien
planet and think you know what this this
alien crap and earth and all these
weird-ass planets if I was a robot I
wouldn't have to put up with this and
then you go about cybernetically
augmenting yourself and putting yourself
above all this weak fleshy stuff and
generally making your cities look like
pointy server towers so what does it
take to achieve true freedom from the
shackles of humanity and to free others
whether they want to be freed or not so
we're in the emancipation victory you
start by getting in touch with old earth
research orbital networks and get that
laser comm satellite up plunk it over
your Brainiac city to earn extra science
to spur you on work to hyper computing
you'll need this to build your
emancipation gates and to build the
angel the ultimate supremacy unit the
emancipation gate is a wonder you
construct in the city of your choice but
you've got to claim a hex to build it on
sorry farmer Reginald Oh put it close to
the mag rail lines that you have
connecting your cities and if you don't
have mag rail lines connecting your
cities now would be a good time to start
unlike the purity victory you won't be
taking units out of your portal to earth
you'll be putting them in I mean how
else are you going to convince the
people of Earth that being a robot
person is cool as hell
if you don't show them some cools hell
robot people you need to commit 1,000
points worth of military might to the
portal so even if you aren't at war it's
time to start building an army and if
you're going to build an army why not
build the baddest ass army you can that
starts with the angel this four-legged
Titan is a throwback to War of the
Worlds or the resistance games or any
other fiction which giant robotic war
platforms make things bad for humans so
if anyone starts giving you guff about
your plans for the folks back home just
send them an angel the combat strength
on this bad boy is formidable and it
makes this super gnarly awesome sound
when it fires
yeah it's not too speedy but a little
Faisal transporter action can make an
angel appear anywhere there's a frack
site source once the gate is complete
it's time to withdraw your troops from
the front and send them back to earth to
wage or re-education campaign you can
only commit one unit per turn so you've
still got some time but once you hit
that threshold congratulations you've
achieved an emancipation victory and
shown all those pathetic meatbags back
on earth the true meaning of evolution
[Music]